for over 30 years scientists have tried
and failed to design a drug that tackles
the cause not the symptoms of
Alzheimer's disease now comes the first
evidence of real success an antibody
infusion that attacks a specific protein
in the brain slowing the development of
early stage Alzheimer's by around a
quarter
professor John Hardy first developed the
theory we said that this approach might
work 30 years ago and you know if you'd
asked me 30 years ago how long it would
take I'd say five to ten years so for me
it's it seems definitely momentous I
think for patients it's a real step
forward a real step forward and
um it's going to take a couple of years
to get it into the system
it's patients like John teeling in the
early stages of the disease who stand to
benefit the most John says he felt the
ground open up when he was diagnosed
he'd Embrace anything that gives him
more time with his wife and family you
put it out of your mind you know what
you're going to end up like and you know
there's nothing you can do about it but
you can't worry about it because there's
nothing you can do
try and be accepting of it the new drug
lecanumab inhibits the buildup in the
brain of a protein called beta amyloid
visible as so-called plaques in the
brains of Alzheimer's patients nearly
1800 patients around the world took part
in the study which showed a 27 slowdown
in the deterioration of their cognitive
skills over 18 months but if approved
the treatment will be laborious and
costly to administer through blood
infusions twice a month and will also
require major investment in screening
for the disease to catch it sufficiently
early and at the moment we do that
through pet scans or through cerebral
spinal fluid testing through from a
lumbar puncture
um and that is uh we need to broaden
access to ways in which we can have
access to those kind of tests we also
want to see new techniques that are
quicker and faster and potentially
cheaper for example blood tests 30
million people around the world suffer
with Alzheimer's in itself just one form
of dementia much difficult and costly
work remains before treatments let alone
cures are widely available but this is a
hugely significant First Step Harry
Fawcett Al Jazeera London